on MVP tonight and it's my pleasure to
present the first time ever Kobe Bryant
all-star MVP award to Kawhi Leonard
[Applause]
Kawai congratulations on that i'm and i
thank you i think the fans here will
attest to the fact when you looked
around and there was not a seat being
used late in the fourth quarter
everybody on their feet and you guys
were were all over the floor tell me
about that fourth quarter man we wanted
to get to a 157 points before they did
but you know they did a great job with
the format this year it had us coming
out playing hard and a fourth quarter
capping for a total points scored and
you know that's pretty much how we got
to competing out there not only playing
to 157 but you're spotting them 9 going
into that fourth quarter yet outscored
by 9 to get there oh yeah we just turned
it up and like I said with the format
made it competitive and we all went out
there and we all wanted to win you ever
seen that in an all-star game where
calls are being argued bodies are being
thrown to the floor and there was that
much intensity in an all-star game not
in a long time it was great
like I said both teams went to the play
our win the game you know the guys over
there taking charges in an all-star game
running back on defense talking and it
was great and you have in your hands
something nobody else has and that's an
MVP all-star game trophy with the name
Kobe Bryant on it what does that mean to
you it means a lot to me you know you
know where's can't even explain just
making us the first Kobe Bryant EP
trophy you know I want to thank Kobe for
everything he's done for me all the long
talks and workouts you know thank you
just this one for him Kawhi Leonard your
MVP of the all-star game 2020 here in
Chicago nice going co-op
coming up